genuine concern I think for the U.S
government I'm in the sense that because
the parent company of tick tock is a
Chinese collect certain information
about the device you use to access the
platform such as your IP address uh user
agent mobile carrier time zone settings
identifiers for advertising purpose
device IDs your screen resolution and
operating system app and file names and
types
on June 29 2020 India announced that
they would have been 59 Chinese apps
including Tick Tock at first many
speculated that this was just a scare
tactic and that the banner would not
last that long but two and a half years
later Tick Tock is still abandoned in
India and it doesn't seem like things
will be changing anytime soon around the
same time that India banned a tick tock
president Donald Trump was making a lot
of commotion about banning Tick Tock as
well he actually nearly succeeded it
given that he introduced an executive
order that banned software updates and
transactions through Tick Tock this
order didn't accomplish all that much
though as President Joe Biden would
swiftly revoke this order after taking
office since then it seemed like the
whole era of tick tock viewers was
finally coming to an end more and more
creators would expand the tick tock or
completely switch to the platform and
for a period Tick Tock even became the
most popular site in the world beating
out google.com it very much seemed that
Tick Tock was here to stay like WhatsApp
YouTube and Instagram but more recently
it appears that Tick-Tock fears have
started to ramp up once again at the end
of 2022 Congress banned a tick tock
across all federally owned devices and
since then this ban has expanded to
basically every institution that's even
vaguely related to the government this
includes dozens of states and public
schools and colleges like the University
of Oklahoma and even UT Austin there's
even a push from the FCC to completely
ban the app from both the Apple App
Store and the Google Play Store and
considering that Apple did not hesitate
to ban fortnite a few years ago they
probably will not hesitate to ban
Tick-Tock especially if they have
government support but likely the
biggest threat for tick tock is the fact
that both sides of Congress are now
taking this issue seriously in December
a Democratic senator suggested that
Donald Trump may have been right about
Tick Tock and that the sooner we bite
the bullet the better so Banning Tick
Tock is no longer just a right-wing
talking point and the US is by no means
the only country having these talks in
fact China themselves does not allow the
global version of tick tock to be used
within their country so why is Tick Tock
getting banned around the world
well the answer isn't rocket science the
reason that Tick Tock is getting banned
is because it's considered a national
security threat but if that was the case
how was Tick Tock able to get so large
in the first place why wasn't Tick Tock
abandoned right from the start or at
least much earlier than now well to
answer this we'll have to take a look
back at the origins of tick tock which
date back to 2012 when a young engineer
named Zhang Yi Ming established a
company called bite dance in Beijing by
danza's first app called it nehanduan D
came out in March of 2012. this app
centered around sharing funny jokes and
memes and while seemingly harmless there
was something much more Sinister going
on in the background like Facebook and
Google the App was very much focused on
collecting user data and this wasn't
Zhang's first rodeo either before
founding bite dance Zhang was developing
an app that could use user data to serve
the news articles that they would be
fond of Zhang simply modified these
algorithms to work with memes and funny
videos and this was a roaring success
within six years of launch the app would
be able to reach a whopping 200 million
users it turns out that when you show
people what they want to hear it's quite
easy to Garner their attention we've
seen a very similar phenomenon in the US
which just led to the creation of echo
Chambers across social media but the
success did not last all that long given
that the CCP would step in in 2018 the
CCP would have been in a honduranzi for
being too vulgar while it's true that
the app did circulate a bunch of dirty
jokes and memes this was likely not the
reason for its ban the real reason came
down to two things one the app was
circulating memes that poked fun at the
Chinese government calling the president
Winnie the Pooh and the two China
prefers that their citizens are
generally doing productive things and
that this app could not be described as
productive by any stretch of the
imagination so that was the end of nehon
duanzi but by chance likely it didn't
mind too much because they had something
much bigger in the works you see it two
years before nahan duanzi got banned by
danz launched another app called Dorian
which is the original Chinese version of
tick tock initially doyin was widely
known as the musically ripoff but that
was honestly more of an insult given
that durian was much more powerful than
musically it ever was the reason well
doyin was built to get users addicted
Zhang used all of his experience from
his news app and his meme app that
concoct an irresistible app it played
into many of our Primal instincts like
our desire for instant gratification and
constant stimulation later in 2016 doyin
would launch outside of China under the
name Tick Tock about one year later by
dance would go ahead and acquire
musically for one billion dollars and
shortly after they would merge the two
apps together giving rise to the tick
tock that we all know today
almost instantaneously Tick Tock caught
the attention of regulators and Country
officials but likely not for the reason
that you would expect the initial
concern up wasn't even National Security
the initial concern centered on the
content itself to put it bluntly many
countries felt that Tick Tock encouraged
brain dead Behavior amongst young people
and objectively speaking this is true
given that we would see trends like
devious licks some countries also felt
that much of tick tock's content was
obscene immoral and vulgar and that this
is very much true as well given that
half the content on Tick Tock is just
thirst traps at first countries simply
tried to talk common sense into people
but when this proved to be ineffective
they started cracking down some
countries decided to punish those that
were producing this content and make
examples out of them Egypt for example
would throw five women in prison for
simply making Tick-Tock videos one of
these women was literally rested for
telling her followers that they could
make money by working with her
fortunately most countries did not go
that far and they simply stopped at
Banning the app like Indonesia
Bangladesh and the Pakistan but wait a
minute isn't China also not a fan of
such unproductive content well yes and
that's why they would crack down as well
but fortunately for pipe dance they
wouldn't go as far as Banning the app
inside it they simply wanted bite dance
to reduce its addictiveness and spread
more positive productive content by
dance would obviously abide it and that
this is what led to Dorian and Tick Tock
becoming completely different platforms
while the app's functionalities are
identical the content is radically
different if you're a kid in China your
daily usage of doing it is limited to 40
minutes and all the content that you're
showing will Center on science
experiments and museums one social media
analyst describes the difference between
doing and Tick Tock as spin image versus
opium but Tick Tock wasn't just shorting
attention spans and getting people
arrested given the insane popularity of
the app it didn't take long for bad
players to start leveraging the platform
in late 2019 for example the Islamic
State started using Tick-Tock to spread
their beliefs they posted content that
showed them capturing people and even
beheadings around the same time Tick
Tock also became a breeding ground for
misinformation relating to covid-19 and
the 2020 election things got so bad that
Tick Tock had to go in and delete 340
000 videos about the 2020 election and
50 000 videos about covert 19. two years
later it doesn't seem like things have
gotten much better on Tick Tock News
Guard found that as much as 20 percent
of new space content on Tick Tock
contained some form of misinformation
clearly this war against misinformation
is very much ongoing but it didn't take
long for countries to realize that all
of this unproductive content Dent was
just a singular battle a distraction the
real war was the Cyber war against China
the idea that Tick Tock collects a bunch
of user data is not a theory it's a fact
it's actually blatantly specified in
their privacy policy on their official
website here are some of the information
that they collect IP address location
data keystroke patterns mobile carrier
and even biometric data including face
prints and voice prints they also
analyze all of the videos that are
posted on the platform to gather further
information about location and the
people in the video and those are just
the variables that Tick Tock openly
admits to collecting in the past Tick
Tock has gone as far as trying to hack
through Apple's privacy policy to
collect more data they have also
successfully bypassed Google security
protocol fortunately Apple and Google
did catch on to this but that just goes
to show how far Tick Tock is willing to
go and the real idea is that if Tick
Tock was truly just trying to serve the
most relevant content and make the most
amount of money possible they would not
go to such extents because they would
not want to risk getting banned by Apple
or Google and risk long-term Revenue but
given that they're willing to risk the
future of the company on collecting more
data their intentions become a lot more
shady and it didn't take long for
evidence to start popping up in August
of 2022 for example Forbes revealed that
300 current Tick Tock and bite dance
employees had previously worked for
Chinese State media while this is
suspicious in its own right the story
doesn't end there for obvious reasons
Tick Tock was not a fan of Forbes
exposing this information so they
started spying on Forbes journalists to
try to identify their sources ironically
Forbes would end up writing a story
about this as well and the craziest part
is that Tick Tock did not even try to
deny the claims they admitted that yes
some of their employees had been spying
up on Forbes journalists however
according to Tick Tock these employees
acted on their own accord and do not
represent the company's actions but you
can take that for what you will also
everything that we're covering it is
simply public info organizations like
the CIA likely have a lot more dirt on
Tick Tock but then why wasn't Tick Tock
banded two and a half years ago in the
US along with countries like India well
the answer is politics two and a half
years ago the 2020 election was just
around the corner and Democrats could
not risk agreeing with Donald Trump as
that could sway swing voters also I'm
not picking on the Democratic party
specifically if Democrats were in power
and they proposed a Tick-Tock ban the
Republicans would not have risked
agreeing with the Democrats either the
Republicans would have probably framed a
tick tock ban as some sort of attack
against free speech and these Party
politics gave Tick Tock the perfect
opportunity to double down it wasn't
until after Joe Biden revoked Trump's
that Tick Tock started collecting
biometric data and trying to bypass
Apple security so it looks like there's
no one to blame for tick tock's power
other than our own government
at this point the evidence against Tick
Tock is becoming irrefutable and the
midterm elections are over so it looks
like both sides of Congress are finally
starting to take action and to do what
they deem is appropriate this appears to
include Banning Tick Tock altogether so
far they've only been to Tick-Tock
across government organizations but it's
also only been one month since they
started taking this threat seriously so
it's more than likely that more bans and
restrictions are around the corner and
while you can argue all you want that
bike dance isn't doing anything that
American companies weren't already doing
the reality is that the US would rather
have American companies have this data
than Chinese companies so if you're an
avid Tick Tock user you might want to
get used to Instagram reels and YouTube
shorts because the era of tick tock May
soon be coming to an end would you
support a Tick-Tock ban comment that
down below also drop a like if you think
that a tick tock detox would be good for
society and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community to suggest
with your video ideas and to consider
subscribing to see more questions and
logically answered until then I'm hurry
and I'll see you guys on the next one